-Hey, everyone.
Let's get to some
thank-you notes.
How about that?
James, could I get some
thank-you note writing music,
please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
Thanks, man.
Wow.
[ Chuckle ]
♪♪
Thank you, Jonathan Swan
interviewing Trump,
for lookin' like someone
who just started
watching "Westworld"
in the middle of Season 3.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Chuckle ] Thank you,
Disney charging $30
to stream "Mulan,"
or, as parents put it,
"No way! That's outrageous!
[ Sigh ] Okay, fine."
-[ Grumbles ]
♪♪
Thank you,
Smartfood
Crunch Berries popcorn,
for really testing the limits
of the words smart and food.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckle ]
-Crunch Berries?
-Yeah.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Men's Wearhouse,
for declaring bankruptcy.
Nobody likes that.
"I guarantee it."
-Aw!
-Too soon.
[ Laughter ]
Too soon!
-Too soon.
♪♪
Thank you,
Pillsbury's new
Snackable Cookie Dough Bites,
for being a great way
to silently tell
the grocery store cashier
that 2020 has beaten you.
[ Laughter ]
There you go, everyone,
those are my thank-you notes!